all right guys
bang bang bill is back uh
what is this round two or round three uh
i think this is three
three oh man i i think that you may be
the only one with three
all right i don't know or maybe there's
somebody else i can't remember but
uh what's up man how are you back by
popular demand
uh crazy times man i don't know um you
know
i know i know a lot of people have it a
lot worse but i really can't wait to get
back out into the world and and and
hug some people i haven't seen in months
but you know if you have to
if you have to be sheltered up i guess
working in the crazy crypto world is
is a good way to go um but uh yeah
it's been a it's been i haven't seen my
employees in person in five months now
so or
four and a half months whatever it is
but you know we're all doing we have to
do and um
you know i call my mom every day and
she's good and i thank my lucky stars
for that
and you know what else could i say
uh yeah i think that's the right way to
look at the world um
give us uh an update or actually before
we do that
give us like the 60 seconds what is
opera
uh before uh if people have not listened
to an episode
sure so abra is a cryptocurrency
wallet bank trading platform allows you
to hold
and buy trade bitcoin ethereum xrp about
100 different cryptocurrencies
allows you to use your your bank
accounts to ach or wire funds to
uh to buy crypto sell crypto uh we
um we just announced last week a new
feature
to earn interest you can earn nine
percent interest on stable coins us
dollars
and four percent interest on bitcoin and
ethereum
uh we also launched launched an
institutional
trading desk which i'm sure we'll talk
about uh hired a new
cio chief investment officer who's
managing a large investment book already
for the company
to generate yield for our consumers um
and we've got a lot of other stuff
coming down the pike but you know
basically
our goal is to be a crypto bank to make
it really easy
for any consumer to get involved in
cryptocurrency
invest trade hold now earn interest
yeah and so as you kind of think about
uh the macro environment obviously
there's the
public health care side uh maybe let's
just start with
what's going on in the economy uh it
seems like
everything has changed we've seen the
government step in and create
uh just a massive trillions of dollars
in quantitative easing and response
they've basically stuffed money in every
exotic corner of the financial system
uh and are looking for more um and it
doesn't look like they're over either
uh and now we're giving talk about uh
wait we actually may optimize
for higher levels of inflation than we
previously have so kind of what's your
take just on like what's been happening
from a macroeconomic standpoint
yeah i wrote about this last week i
think that this is a pivotal moment
for for bitcoin as as a new asset class
for a couple of reasons right
we've never had the government come out
and say our stated
aim is to create inflation
above three percent and now you know
we're looking at potentially four
percent i don't think they've actually
said it yet but i believe they're
the rumor is they're going to they've
more or less said it's the discussion
they're going to set a name for four
percent inflation i think that they feel
they have no choice
except to basically re reflate the
economy in order to create growth
whether we like that idea whether we
think it's a good idea or better i don't
think it really matters that's what
they're going to do
and so their stated aim has never been
and never will be to protect the value
of your money or your wealth right by
definition
they are willing to erode the value of
your money
in order to create movement in the
system which is what creates growth
movement means moving money
borrowing money paying back money loans
whatever
but that liquidity is what ultimately
creates growth and what they've said is
is that
we're okay and history has proven this
because a dollar today is worth 99
less than it was a hundred years ago
they've proven that they're willing to
inflate the value of money to the point
where your money is worthless in order
to do that
it's just that we've never had a
government the u.s government come out
with a stated
aim to create inflation so high price
inflation but that's also going to
basically only be caused by currency
inflation right
and so we we don't understand a lot of
people the difference between currency
inflation
and price inflation everybody focuses on
price inflation
as somebody used to collect baseball
cards as a kid i understand
also currency inflation right i mean if
you have the only mickey mantle
rookie card in existence and all of a
sudden you find out there's two of them
it stands to reason that the one that
you had should be worth less than it was
before
but we print money without end
and don't think the same way about the
fact that we keep adding more of this
artificial
paper uh into into circulation and so
my point is is that this has never been
a we've never had a better time
for bitcoin to stake its claim not that
it needs our help but but for bitcoin to
stake its claim as the de facto
hard digital asset uh that i think it's
going to
going to become and i'm not sure it
needed a nudge from our government but
it's getting one
nonetheless yeah it's almost this belief
of uh if you didn't understand money
sound money inflation all that kind of
stuff they're literally running a
multi-trillion dollar uh marketing
campaign
for learning about this stuff and now
what people are starting to realize is
wait a second what are my options i got
like people
that i've talked with basically go
through kind of a a journey so they
start with i know nothing
uh oh wait a second if the government's
gonna print a bunch of money
all i know is that my government usually
screws me somewhere it's like how are
they screwing me
right okay they're gonna devalue this
currency thing i don't really understand
what that means let me learn about it
okay now i understand it what are all of
the options i have to protect myself
and this is i mean literally stocks
getting inflated to real estate to
precious metals to bitcoin to
you know whatever you want yeah and i
think that
what people are starting to understand
is uh
the provable scarcity right that's why i
keep hammering on this point that like
we don't know how much gold exists in
the world we don't know what the total
addressable market of uh gold is the
total supply now that doesn't mean that
all of a sudden gold is going to fall
from the sky
and the you know the cap that we think
or the circulating supply is going to
double overnight
it's just the fact that you can't prove
it and so it feels very kind of
antiquated
only when compared to this new system
which is provably scarce right and so
it's like it was the best we had now we
have a new system the new system in
comparison looks way better
but it's going to take time for people
to kind of understand those differences
right
absolutely and by the way the government
never had a stated goal to protect the
value of your money
i mean that has never been on the table
right they've never
said hey the role of of the central bank
or the role of the treasury is to
protect your wealth
their role ultimately is to manage a
house of cards
right and i don't know and i don't mean
that necessarily in a derogatory way it
is what it is
right we've had this system for 100
years it's created more wealth than any
other system in history
uh and in 2008 we saw what happens when
you don't manage the house of cards
correctly it starts to buckle under its
own weights
people get overly greedy we we do we
need a certain amount of
of let's call it greed but but whenever
when the system basically
gets overly greedy it buckles under its
own weight and the government can no
longer manage the house of cards
correctly
but that's its writ from its perspective
from a financial perspective is to
manage the house of card not to preserve
anthony's or bill's wealth
yeah well and it also feels like um
you'll love this uh
i wrote a piece called the wizard of oz
are the wizards of the federal reserve
it was based on the wizard of oz which
is you know they think that it's the
all-knowing all all whatever powerful
person and then it just turns out to be
like a regular guy
and i think that's kind of what we're
seeing with uh the federal reserve which
is
again there's really really smart
intelligent uh people who mean well
and they're doing the best they can it's
just we're basically giving them an
impossible task which is hey
manage this highly complex uh intricate
system called an economy
which that is their job is to manage the
economy not to manage the currency um
and so when we asked them to do that
even if they were successful which they
usually do not have
kind of true control they kind of just
directly can push it one way or the
other
even if they did their task is to manage
the economy
not to your point manage the currency
and the way that they manage that
economy is by manipulating the value of
the currency you that you sit with
in your bank account right you're
starting to think about uh do you
know if you're a matrix fan but if you
if you watch the second matrix movie
when the architect says this is the
the umpteenth incarnation of the matrix
right and we're getting exceedingly good
at it well i feel like
you know because every government issued
currency has
so far has failed and is and it appears
that that trend has
uh has no reason to stop it will
continue unabated
and that we're basically going to have
to recreate our our analog matrix again
with the government trying to print more
money from scratch and we've seen it
with other countries in argentina where
where those poor people have watched
their currency fail over and over again
and it but but on the other hand up
until now it's been the best system
for managing an economy and what i don't
know yet is how we go from bitcoin
preserving wealth to bitcoin and crypto
helping to manage
an economy now that would be something
uh but at a minimum
we know that it's phenomenal for
preserving wealth and
and will have a bigger role in that in
that you know
in that world but i also think that over
time uh you're going to see crypto and i
think we're going to start with stable
coins but eventually move to
to even um you know provably scarce
cryptocurrencies like you said
having a key role in uh and even
managing the economy
so recently there was uh
one of the uh the uh inevitable first
which is uh there's a publicly listed
company called microstrategy
a gentleman mr sailor decides that
uh he's gonna take it looks like about
20 of his balance sheet
uh and he's going to move it from cash
or us dollars
into bitcoin but he's not doing it as
uh what i think many would refer to as
kind of a speculative
uninformed um you know gamble
right he basically clearly articulates
concerns with the macro economy
with inflation uh with the idea that
that cash is likely to
drastically be devalued um in the coming
months and years
and so he is using this as uh a hedge
and literally at one point says i'm
gonna use bitcoin as a reserve asset
uh and so it's it's kind of a currency
uh play more than it is like a
speculative i think you know bitcoin's
gonna
drastically increase in value in the
future or anything like that what's your
general take on
uh kind of seeing this news yeah i mean
you know plan b
kind of this has become kind of the
nostradamus of of crypto lately uh or
the person we want to be the nostradamus
of crypto i'll say uh
because we all want his his model to to
come true
actually predicted that at some point
bitcoin will become
an asset class beyond just digital gold
where it is actually used for these
purposes and it's it's fascinating to
see that
uh granted a small cap company but i i
would i would suspect it would start
with a small cap company and not start
with with apple treasury
uh would would embrace uh cryptocurrency
as as an inflation hedge whether it's
currency inflation or price inflation or
both
and clearly now now first of all this is
let's let's be clear this is a small cap
company um
he mentioned this in past i would say
almost in passing
uh in a quarterly report maybe two or
three weeks ago
realized he was getting a [ __ ] ton of
press by doing this and is now taking
advantage of that press i'm not saying
that that's a good thing or bad thing he
just is that's what that's what they're
doing
um but be that as it may they're still
doing it
and i think that sends a an incredible
message
because if you've got the cash it's way
easier
to just sit on the cash uh make two
percent
uh one and a half percent whatever it is
if you've got a good treasury and
and call it a day right nobody's gonna
get fired for doing that
no one right you now you can get fired
for basically putting money in in
bitcoin
on one of those 40 days where you put it
in and it happens to to go down
i i you know now if you've got a
long-term perspective and
and you don't care right now the last 11
years of history as a guide
say okay you've got a more than
reasonable chance that in dollar terms
what you're investing is going to be
worth more
than than what you put in so anyway
we'll see where this goes but it was
almost inevitable it's just fascinating
to see how
the first um the first really
interesting opportunity here
with the treasury embracing bitcoin
happened to come about
uh he's definitely milking it i have no
problem with that uh
but um you know i think what's going to
be more interesting to see
does anyone else follow suit does a
company
in like you know the the fortune
1000 embrace a certain amount of crypto
has it already happened and we don't
know about it they don't have to i don't
think they have to disclose
uh to investors how they manage treasury
uh unless it's a meaningful
you know percentage of their other book
so so i think what happens
next is is even more important but this
is fascinating
and my twitter crypto twitter has
exploded in the last few hours everybody
talking about this and so
um you know like i said what comes next
that's what i want to see
yeah part of to me that is so
interesting is
uh this isn't like a random company
on this like obscure exchange in some
foreign country
this is a an american company that's got
a market capital over a billion dollars
it's not like they took one percent
right you know it looks like 20
250 million dollars bought them about 22
000 bitcoin give or take uh and
it's traded on the nasdaq like i think
that you know when people first start
thinking about this it's kind of like
governments like the nefarious
governments always do the
the weird stuff first and then it
becomes mainstream right uh
not saying that there's companies that
are necessarily nefarious but just the
ones that are on the fringe usually do
some of this stuff first right
this is a nasdaq traded business that's
a billion dollar plus market cap and
the move was with hundreds of millions
of dollars
i think that that ends up being uh just
as important
as it actually happening right it's kind
of like who does it
and when does it happen right and at the
start of kind of these bull markets
seeing something like this
you start looking around the room and
you say hey you know what company
what size or what type of company uh if
they pursue this and they go ahead and
do it
is the like paul tudor jones moment
where now also the career risk is
removed because
oh apple did it or you know maybe it's
not to be that big of a company maybe it
can be a
10 billion dollar company or you know
what whatever it is there's some level
where the tipping point happens people
say i no longer have career risks to do
this because so and so did it
i just don't know where that that kind
of barometer is sure but but we've had
these
in the mid 90s we were having
discussions about the internet where we
would have conversations but well nobody
gets fired for
you know integrating with some
conglomerates edi system
for supply chain management right and
most of your audience doesn't even know
what the hell i just said
so so my point is is that there was a
transition to the internet where
it wasn't necessarily a safe bet because
the internet was porn and gambling
uh from 93 to 96 and in most people's
minds and then all of a sudden it
exploded and it was mainstream and why
the hell don't you have an internet
strategy
and and i think the time is coming where
finance departments are going to need to
have
a crypto bitcoin maybe defy strategy i'm
a little skeptical but we'll
we'll see what happens you know and and
so some
some variation on that with its own
terminology that's going to unfold over
the next 10 years
uh is going to change corporate finance
right
you know treasurers and others within
the company are going to are going to
look at
you know collateralized lending in
crypto for
for for corporate growth and it's a
topic that didn't exist
in traditional finance five years ago
right so so the whole lexicon
uh the the strategies that enables it's
all going to change
and this is this is just a very you know
obviously buying and holding a small
relative even if it's 20 of your cash in
the grand scheme of things
in the united states it's a relatively
small amount of money but it still sends
a message
right the same way that the first
company moved their supply chain onto
the internet in 1997
sent a message yeah it also feels like
there's
multiple uh trends or patterns all
converging
for this like perfect storm right so uh
last year i wrote a piece saying
uh rocket fuel for bitcoin actually i
think maybe at the bitcoin 2020
conference or 2019 conference
uh you and i also um had this
conversation where it was like
look you're gonna get the rates
drawn down you're gonna get massive
money printing and that's all going to
coincide
you know relatively at the same time as
the bitcoin having
and this like quantitative tightening
mechanism is wildly misunderstood
um and frankly uh most people don't even
realize it's happening and in many cases
especially if they're not in the bitcoin
world
and so you get those three trends right
you get rates down money up and
bitcoin having should be rocket fuel
alone but then you start to add in paul
tudor jones you should add in you know
large public companies like
all of these things are happening within
i mean we're still what 90 days
from the the having like you know you're
you're basically plus or minus
three months on either side of the
having all of this is occurring
you just got to look towards you know
the next year and say like
how how does it not happen right right
and and
that's what i spend a lot of time
thinking about but i also think that
uh bitcoin's place was inevitable the
fact that we happen to be
in the late stages of a multi-decade
debt cycle
um is just the perfect storm that
doesn't mean that bitcoin wouldn't have
worked
otherwise right i mean there's a fourth
factor which which goes into being late
stage uh dead cycle and that's populism
the rise of populism actually is not a
it's not an accident
it wasn't caused by trump that the late
stage debt cycle enabled
trump because it's creating uh haves and
have-nots
at a predictable way at a very large
scale
all of this is exacerbating uh
in a positive way you know the the
onslaught and the interest
in in bitcoin crypto and and the
technology and everything else define
now whatever
um and it's not going to stop the you
know the bulls are out of the gate
they're they're marching down you know
the the alleyways and they're not
stopping
and the question now is is okay um
like i said with with paul tudor jones i
had the same reaction you know what's
next you know you saw goldman actually
move a full partner now to to run crypto
um and uh you know you mentioned tudor
jones but then you've got micro
anyway all of these pieces are coming
into play in a way that basically looks
to me like an accelerant
for what was going to happen anyway
right
and that's really exciting because you
know last year it was all about the etf
and now
and a bunch of other you know waiting
for the government to do stuff and i
think now there's this groundswell of
realizing
hey i don't think we have to wait i
don't think that the occ's announcement
changed anything i don't think that
tudor jones cared
about the otc announcement i don't think
that uh
the guy the ceo of microstrategy
whatever the company's called
even knows about the occ announcement or
or or cares about the sec's opinion on
ico
they just look at this in a common sense
way
printer's going with what's the mean
berber and and
you know money's going to zero and this
is a this is a
better way to to look at money right and
and so
like i said the timing could not be
better right and i think that
the we will look back on the
announcement
of the fed creating a four percent
target
as the pivotal moment for bitcoin going
from
technology enabling provably scarce
digital money
to this is necessary
for having a real internet digital
i don't know what the right phrases
internet provably scarce digital asset
for the globe
right that is not governable
by any central government right and and
i think that announcement is the pivotal
moment
uh or will be the pivotal moment in
history uh for bitcoin
why do you think four percent um
i don't even think it four percent is
the key number i think it's the fact
that the government is saying
that significantly higher inflation
is our stated goal and
that combined with the fact that the way
quantitative easing is working
is likely to end up losing money
for the fed at scale because at some
point these ious
have to be paid back i don't see
how this ends up being only four percent
somebody's got to pay those ious back
and i think it ends up being treasury at
scale right and so that can only be done
by basically borrowing more and printing
more which creates even
wider uh class you know bigger class
warfare problems
etc etc so so the four percent is not
necessarily
the key the key is is that we are
acknowledging
that we basically created a big problem
and we don't have any way out
except to massively reflate the economy
because of the fact that we're
again most of the public like you point
about the wizard of oz behind the
curtain doesn't understand the fact that
this is a managed house of cards
and the only way out of this is in the
late stage debt cycle is to reflate the
economy
or we end up in a great depression so
you know from their perspective i'm not
saying that's true
i'm just saying pick your poison from
their perspective and they've picked
their poison which is massive inflation
the other part that uh shocks me is how
many people believe
inflation is evenly distributed that's
right
it's mind-blowing like the amount of
income disparity created
and wealth disparity created by
government initiated inflation is just
it's just my blood uh and
i i've given up on this idea that the
masses will ever get it
um if you know even people in argentina
and other places where
they've tried to they just don't get it
and
i i it's something it's not about
behavioral economics
i think that part of it is is that
people still believe in the dream
like i if i work hard or if i'm an
entrepreneur
um i can get my share of that pie
and that's great i i i've always
believed in that as well but
but now we've got this it's accelerating
because of where we are in this debt
cycle and
and and you can't stop it now
it just can't be stopped and and so i
think that
that's a freight train that people just
don't see don't see coming
it manifests itself like i said in
populism and other things but
but um i think that that is going to get
significantly worse before it gets
better
yeah what's interesting to me is uh not
only one
on a geographic basis but even inside
single economies right there's a study
in uh in europe
and i wish somebody would do it in the
united states or maybe somebody has i
just haven't found the study yet
but they basically looked at coming out
of the 2008 2009 crisis
um they said well does everyone
experience the same inflation like cpi
numbers never went above two percent you
know yada yada whatever
and they realized that like no if you
break down a
uh society into kind of 20 buckets you
got the top 20 percent the next 20
percent
all the way down to the bottom 20 of on
socioeconomic uh spectrum
the bottom 20 of the socio-economic
ladder
ended up experiencing they believe
somewhere between six to 10 percent
inflation coming out of the 0809 crisis
and it makes sense theoretically right
like of course you're devaluing the
currency
so the people who hold only currency are
going to get way more inflation impact
than the people who have investable
assets
all the way up to the people who
majority of their net worth is
investable assets and they kind of
experience the lowest inflation
but that's not like a well-documented
nor like highly talked about component
here right so four percent inflation
target
could actually legitimately and this is
going to sound crazy to people
but that could be fifteen to twenty
percent inflation from the bottom i
don't think that's crazy at all
i think being poor has always been
incredibly expensive um you know i i
i've been fortunate financially and i'm
always getting
banks and other you know hey take this
free loan you know
or they want my deposits whatever it is
right it's it's basically
all these free services being thrown at
me where somebody who
probably needs that money a thousand
times more than i do would pay
50 x and fees for the same services and
that's going to get worse um and i think
you're right i think that
uh the four percent average is going to
have a
a kind of standard deviation across the
income pyramid in any one geography that
is
very significant i think if you look at
the cities in particular
um there's going to be like a huge uh
standard deviation like between the mean
on on the hams and have-nots from a you
know socio-economic perspective
the part that's crazy to me is imagine
in the united states having
20 of the population experienced 20
inflation
like that like that is just absolutely
mind-blowing to the point where
we do not have the government or social
programs in place to deal with that
we don't have the kind of mainstream
media or legacy media that is prepared
to have that conversation
right i mean it's just you can almost
see it on the horizon
and i think part of the bitcoin story
very quickly is going to turn into
look buying a house or buying a bunch of
stocks or you know all this kind of
stuff that all
requires you to be an investor right
there's some in some form or fashion
bitcoin i think is going to take this
narrative of kind of the savings
technology
right it is the um that the protection
uh which i think would be very
interesting and you see it obviously
with the corporations now
um but you could see that happening at
the individual level as well yeah
but i mean this what's interesting about
that
perspective is that i mean von mises
hayek and others they wrote about this
before bitcoin existed
right that the idea that a deflation
that what would happen with the
deflationary asset
if one truly existed is exactly what
we're seeing with
you know these these stock to flow
models they intuitively understood
what a stock to flow model would look
like for a hard asset like
like gold if it actually ever became
money again and
and we're seeing that play out i mean
it's it's basically playing that
playbook
to the letter the challenge with that is
is that it's still being held by a very
small number of people
and you know part of my stated aim is to
with abra is to solve that problem by
getting bitcoin and crypto in the hands
of more people and then ultimately
making it utilitarian not just
um just but not just at the store value
and an investment
to prison as it or you know hedge
against the future
um but until that happens it hasn't
happened and right now you know there's
a very small number of people that are
holding the vast majority
of of bitcoin out there and i think as a
community
um we should all be doing our part to to
kind of
spread spread the wealth as they say uh
and incentivize people not to give it
away but to incentivize people to want
to invest in it because uh it's in their
um it's in their best interest to have a
small percentage at a minimum
of their of their net worth and the good
news is i'm getting
droves of people online you know coming
to me now saying hey i want to get into
this
how do i start and it comes in cycles
right i mean we
i had a lot of this happening in
february of 18 um
but it feels different this time um it
doesn't feel like
uh hey i just need to get in and out
quick like like before it felt like
like i i'm missing the boat on a
get-rich-quick thing
now it feels like hey i need to be
exposed to this i need to understand how
this works
not just i want to buy some now can you
help me get started i want to educate
myself
right where can i go to read stuff and
so so i'm seeing way more of that
now than i did when we had the kind of
let's call it you know january 18 pump
uh and that's that's very encouraging to
me but but it's we're just scratching
the surface
um keeping in mind that you know a
billion people out there probably still
don't even
have never heard of bitcoin um which is
hard to believe but it's
and that may be that's probably too
small of a number or if they've heard of
it they have no idea that it's a
currency or whatever right so
so uh you know especially in silicon
valley i mean i've gone from bubble to
bubble bubble
over the last 25 years and so so we need
to basically
get this outside of that bubble
for sure what have you guys done
differently at opera or
anything in terms of not so much to do
products and features and things like
that but
help us understand kind of how you're
thinking about navigating
all this chaos and and i think what many
of us believe will be a pretty
big influx of new users to the space
over the next 18 months or so
yeah you have to be first of all you
have to be mission driven
as a company because and the mission
when it comes to something like this has
to involve a very long-term view
any investor in amber who's basically in
this for
you know a two three year turnaround
it's going to be very disappointing not
that we're not making money
but you know if our goal is to get to
100 million
and a billion retail consumers not just
traders but retail consumers
don't trade using this stuff um
it's it's a lot of content right we
produce a ton of content as a company
from
onboarding to training to uh
macroeconomic discussions like this i
host an ama
every single friday which we have to put
a lot of prep work into and as you know
posting this uh and so and and because
we go very deep
uh like on certain topics it does
involve a tremendous amount of prep work
but that's
what we signed up for and so so if if if
you look at our site like we have
a beginner overview of every single
major
cryptocurrency like from market cap
perspective like in the top
50 i think and people read it and they
send us questions you know and support
like i don't understand this or i
understand that or
or or in the ama and so um
and so you have to basically be willing
to go one to one
like like like almost like uh grass door
grassroots campaign
uh grassroots campaign door-to-door to
knock on doors saying you know here's my
candidate right so so
we're doing that for bitcoin and for
crypto and it's a slog
but the the the reward comes in the fact
that we have
you know hundreds of thousands of
wallets processing billions of dollars
in transaction volume and it's all good
but
but but ultimately it's still
being bitcoin is still being held by a
relatively small number of people
after all those efforts so so i believe
that
by turning this into a real crypto bank
with earn interest
uh you know borrow against your holdings
uh trade against 100 different
cryptocurrencies
eventually with hundreds of thousands of
wallets it reaches the tipping point
and that's what we're fully committed to
and whether it takes another five years
another 10 years honestly i don't care
because i know we one i know we can
build a profitable sustainable business
along the way
and whenever that tipping point happens
uh that just means
you know we have more income to invest
more and more product um
and to reach more places and my goal is
to start at the top of the pyramid and
work my way down to the bottom of the
period i spent a lot of time
launching mobile money systems in haiti
for example and this you know bitcoin is
is not going to solve the problems of
the people in haiti in the short term
but in the long term i think it can make
a big difference when they don't have to
basically deal with corrupt governments
to to manage their currency that's a big
problem
right you know i would say by and large
the people working in government in the
united states are not corrupt
they're misguided miseducated
misinformed
but not overtly fraudulently corrupt on
the other hand
a lot of governments in places that are
dirt poor
are overtly corrupt and that manifests
itself
in terms of worthless currencies
worthless economies et cetera et cetera
in the long term long term bitcoin
solves that it solves it today in theory
but it's not going to happen
all right so so i want to basically get
bitcoin from here down
here and if it takes 20 years 25 years
so be it
and so help me understand how do you
guys think about
um like your treasury management right
and specifically around like we see
public companies doing this obviously
crypto
companies have tons and tons of crypto
kind of
called flying around right you're having
to um
uh finalize transactions right there's
you got to pay vendors some vendors want
to be paid in cash someone will be paid
in bitcoin like
there's all these moving parts like how
does a crypto company
like uh the one you run think about
treasury management uh today given kind
of the macro environment and also the
crypto environment
yeah so so we have so there's two parts
that there's
customer funds and then there's our own
balance sheet so let's talk about
customer funds first i think that's a
more interesting part of the question
so so we custody funds in two ways
oh actually three ways that ever right
the first is uh for
the trading accounts and those are
basically custodied on an exchange
and we go deep with them on their
security practices
and you know how they manage cold
storage versus warm storage
um and then how we effectively can
access those accounts on behalf of our
consumers via
uh secure api and execute trades okay so
that's
that's uh that's pure crypto um
and um you know we don't we don't make
any incremental money on that it's
usually a small spread on on the
movement between asset classes there's
no
rep application of that and you can't
because
you have money transmitter licensing
regulations and things like that where
the state of purpose has to be very very
clear then we have our interest bearing
accounts
uh which are both crypto crypto in the
sense of bitcoin ethereum as well as
crypto in the sense of stable coins or
dollar deposits
and the stated aim of those accounts is
to generate interest
on behalf of our for our consumers
uh via our partner in this case prime
trust a
us chartered trust company and
we run an institutional lending desk
which is the third part of this which
then
manages a lending book and reports to an
investment committee that i'm part of
that then determines um who the the the
best lending or what the best lending
opportunities are to generate
safe yield uh in the crypto sphere for
for those assets
and that's a combination of of balance
sheet risk versus collateralization et
cetera et cetera and so
so there's also treasury then for
collateral management and and
uh a certain amount of qualification on
on collateral so
so all of that factors into how we uh
how we manage consumer funds now
on the average treasury it's different
because the vast majority
of our um uh supplies
or our money goes to paying people
that's like by far number one expense
and the vast majority of people still
want to be paid in dollars um
a few people would like to be to be paid
in bitcoin and that's fine um
but um we are not at a point yet where
we can manage our treasury
uh in in in bitcoin uh i would love to
to get to that point uh we don't we're
always holding a certain amount of
bitcoin as a company
um not just on behalf of the consumers
but our own bitcoin as well but but it's
it's not
a majority or anything like that uh but
i would like to get there
eventually uh and part of that is even
though we have
a lot of investors who are crypto first
like you know
like blockchain capital and others who
only invest in stuff
we also have other investors like
american express for example or
you know a fund backed by fidelity um
who you know if we told them that we
were holding 65 percent of the money in
bitcoin
uh i i'd be having a board meeting
tomorrow i can promise you that
not that they would stop me but they
would certainly have a lot of questions
right uh anyway long answer your
question uh but
um you know so there's there's two parts
there the consumer and
the company part and then you guys just
hired a new cio
right yeah tell me about that yeah so
young cho i joined us he was
at celsius earlier uh and then before
that he worked in traditional lending
i was at a company called alt lending he
was at city uh you know
as a back room both already in crypto uh
and before that traditional lending
and uh he has very quietly over the past
several months along with others in my
team
uh built this new institutional lending
desk which has already gone very deep in
building partnerships all over the
crypto sphere
uh if if people um are institutional
uh the traders or or other funds
and have a need to to either borrow or
lend
they can approach abra and we'll dig
into what their needs are
and um you know usually we'll be able to
help so um
word has already gotten out on the
street that we're doing this and so we
have a lot of people approaching us but
for those who didn't know
you know they can certainly approach me
or the company but but young is a
fantastic background in this
uh we've taken a relatively conservative
approach we don't put
a lot of eggs in one basket we create a
a good diversified
portfolio and that's part of the
challenge here uh because we did get
we're getting a large influx of deposits
already
we kind of expected it because the rates
are so high right now
and we hope they stay there but the
challenge is to make sure that we
continue to build a widely diversified
portfolio and not just you know put all
of our eggs in one basket where
you know some investor does something
silly where you know we're in trouble
and and so
i do worry a little bit about what i see
in some of the
the other uh kind of c5 plays out there
that you know there's there's a lot of
centralization
uh in some of the investments we're
seeing and i hope that people will take
a hard look at that and start to
diversify more
um but um it's something it's one of the
reasons we hired him and
started this team long before we uh
before we announced the
uh the consumer product was to make sure
that we could build a well-diversified
portfolio
and i want to end up on uh this idea of
a crypto bank
which is uh something that you've
mentioned to me multiple times and
in past episodes we've talked about but
like what does that look like
today and kind of how do you view the
path
to building it because those two words
uh historically
i think in some weird way have been like
uh antithetical to each other
right where crypto wants to you know
literally long bitcoin short the bankers
type uh
you know thought process um but to want
to build a crypto bank i think is not
necessarily like let's go build
you know the the next traditional bank
and just hold crypto it looks like
something different so maybe talk about
that a little bit
yeah sure so so six years ago
if she said crypto bank to me that was
probably dropbox
uh or what you know taking dropbox and
making it into bitco
uh love bitco i think they provide
fantastic services
uh i'm talking about their original
service which was you know really just a
multi-sig storage capability
um and and i only say just because
they've really evolved tremendously even
though their original service adds a lot
of value still
um but but what i mean when i say crypto
bank now
is an evolving analogous stack to the
traditional banking system that's
specific to crypto
so the ability to earn the ability to
trade
the ability to hold securely if you
don't want to do those things the
ability to borrow
the ability to pay and spend but all
based on crypto rails
in some cases the consumer will know
they're using crypto
because i'm i'm you know holding bitcoin
or xrp or whatever whatever theory
whatever i want to do
in some cases i may be holding what
looks like dollars
but using crypto rails like in the form
of a stable coin
uh you know you'll see abra doing some
more more in that area
in the coming months but you end up with
this uh
kind of and it's global by the way right
so so and i haven't layered
regulation on top of that yet but but
i'm just talking in from from a vision
perspective
a single global entity that can allow
people to
uh earn spends save borrow
invest all one platform all globally
all taking advantage of bitcoin and
crypto rails where it makes sense
um you know what think about supply
chain finance
right a lot of american investors are
shut out of agents asian supply chain
deals
which can be very lucrative because they
can't move money around and they don't
have access
well stable coins actually solve that
problem because you can actually move
money around
very very quickly to fund supply chain
finance deals
so i predict you're going to see crypto
banks
enabling yield making investments like
that in high grade
opportunities in the coming years makes
perfect sense
right because it's yield that we're
simply not getting with
massive trillion dollar cash stock funds
right so
so these are the kinds of of kind of
opportunities that are enabled by the
crypto bank
so it's a new stack but it has its
analogy in the old stack
if that makes sense and we simply want
to be and there's going to be several of
them right
we simply want to be one that is
easy to access transparent um
highly educational and trustworthy and
we talk about it all the time
it drives features and everything we do
even if people don't see it in the short
term
right so it's a it's a slow methodical
march and a feature by feature basis
towards getting to that to that vision
and do you think that this will be
centralized decentralized
maybe there's a spectrum between some
products or features have to be
centralized versus decentralized how do
you think about the
decentralization um in building
something like that
well my answer is yes i think i think
the
the biggest opportunity well the biggest
advantage for
decentralization right now is regulatory
arbitrage
clearly right and and i don't again i'm
not making a judgment on that it just is
what it is
um but there is no such thing as true
defy yet to me d5 means
with the exception of bitcoin where
meaning is there an off switch
right and so all of these early defy
systems
if if a regulator came in to a certain
group and said shut it down
you're going to jail they would figure
out how to shut it down
if the government came to you and said
pomp you're the arbiter of all things
bitcoin shut it down
you'd get go out to the community and
say okay i've been told to shut it down
and they go [ __ ] you we can't shut it
down because
one we're not going to and two there is
no off switch and and so
there is that off switch in most of
these d5 systems and so for example
a smart contract requires information
from the outside world that's provided
via work
well if the oracle is talking to the
outside world it's got an off switch by
definition and if you shut it off
there's no more smart contract so it's
not very smart so
then now this company's trying to create
decentralized oracles to eliminate that
piece and so
so the regulatory arbitrage isn't even
really quite
there yet people are simply getting away
with certain things that's not
regulatory arbitrage it just hasn't
woken up the giant yet because you're
not big enough
for them to care and i think that's
going to change and so i think a lot of
the vcs that are pumping money very
quickly into d fire
may be in for a rude regulatory
awakening and as somebody who spent a
lot of time and money
uh having my own awakenings i can tell
you that they're not fun
and and so i don't know how that plays
out over time
but um i do think there's value in that
i think if you want to run a system
that's truly global truly accessible
doesn't answer to the man the the theory
of defy is
very interesting and we'll see if the
reality of it gets there in the meantime
the fact that i have a chief investment
officer who knows what he's doing
responds to a committee
that committee reports to a board that
board reports to investors
to me adds a lot of value to consumers
um and you also have the opportunity if
you don't want to play in that system to
take bitcoin put it in a hardware wallet
and not deal with any of it and that to
me is super interesting i do both
i have bitcoin in a hardware wallet that
nobody could find it
and i have bitcoin in abra earning
interest and i have
cash in a bank and i have cash and ab er
earning nine percent interest so
so there's different ways that crypto
will be used by different people over
time
and it's up incumbent upon us to add
value
versus simply you know assuming that
everybody should just throw it in a
hardware wall
it's it's so fascinating when you start
to look at this uh this idea of um
so many early attempts of using um kind
of the
the bitcoin ethos or the blockchain
technology
uh was simply just taking uh something
that already existed and and
quote-unquote
uh copying it in this new world but
there's no actual like innovation or
breakthrough
i think what we found in the internet
was if you just took your business model
put on the internet
you got like 10 of the value of the
internet right but it was the people who
realized wait what does the internet
empower that i previously couldn't do
right and so i always use the the
example of like media if you just check
your newspaper
and like turn it into a pdf and put it
on the internet like yeah sure maybe
some people could uh
could log in or whatever but that's not
really very valuable
compared to what ultimately ended up
being the value of you could change
headlines you could do
dynamic updates to the articles you
could have slide
i mean like you could do so many
different things and i think that's what
we're seeing here with
a lot of the the finance stuff and then
on top of that the decentralization
um you know this is a troll comment and
i say it
i preface it because people always freak
out but like supposedly
uh over 60 percent of all the ethereum
nodes in the world for example
run on cloud providers and majority of
those are on amazon's aws
and so again it doesn't mean that uh
ethereum doesn't have value
it just means that it's not nearly as
decentralized as i think people want to
believe
right and by the way that that's fine
it's not necessarily like a a fatal
thing or whatever but to your point
uh people just have to understand like
there is the possibility that
you know if the federal government came
in and said hey we want if you're a
cloud provider and you're running a defy
application you have to shut it down
yeah you shut down a lot of all coins
could be shut down
in hours by a couple of governments with
no i don't know if they know this but
they're certainly capable of doing it if
they were incentivized or motivated for
whatever reason i can't imagine they
would be right now but
but yes and and shutting down aws would
be
a very quick way of shutting down a
whole bunch of points for sure
uh by the way it wouldn't help abra
either but but you know abber's also not
running a coin so
um but yes to your point and we we also
don't claim to be a decentralized
company
right but i think i think that's the
piece right is like
i i think that in some weird way like uh
centralization has almost become like
the enemy
right and people like want to point in
and be like oh that's so bad like you're
centralized
and it's like yeah well the things you
think are decentralized probably aren't
as decentralized
and also it's not that centralization is
always bad it's just a trade-off
right there's pros and cons to
centralization versus decentralization
and so depending on what you're trying
to build you should then make a decision
as to
what you want to do right absolutely i
mean to me that's that's the beauty of
um
you know what was brand's service for
file sharing um bittorrent right
you know bittorrent doesn't have that
problem there's no aws to shut down
for bittorrent what i want is i want a
twitter i want a facebook and i want
services that run on that model
not on a corporate aws model
uh but that's for me personally right
and so you know the company started and
my guess is their first versions would
probably be running on aws
and you know the same the same cloud
services to your point
yeah it'll uh it will be very
interesting to see and
and by the way one of the things that is
pushing people i think in this direction
is like the tick tock saga
yeah i mean if tick tock was
decentralized
then you wouldn't have this conversation
that's exactly what i
i want decentralized versions of those
services that
there's no chinese firewall against
there's no trump executive order against
it's just out there just like you can't
shut off bittorrent the music industry
tried for years to shut up bittorrent
and they gave up now they'll sue certain
users
which is crazy but they've proven that
they can find users but
that's the user's problem because they
don't run vpns or tor or whatever
um i'm not and i'm not saying people
should illegally share share music i'm
simply saying
that those decentralized tools uh exist
and if they're used correctly we could
actually recreate
a lot of these services today it's just
a question of people's incentives for
doing that
absolutely wild um two questions for you
to wrap up
uh first being what do you think plays
out over the next 18 months in crypto
like what are the milestones or
events that you're paying attention to
and uh and specifically looking for
yeah i'm looking for um
a number of wallets you know i look at
how many unique
uh we try to decipher it in terms of
unique individuals it's very hard
because a lot of it is uh you know it's
not reported it's unclear anybody can
create
a crypto address but for us um the key
stats uh i'll tell you the average stats
and then the macro stats
so so we want to see um you know
a couple of 100 million people actively
using holding bitcoin over the next 18
months and i think that's going to be
the
the biggest um advantage of the next
run-up in price to me is going to be
just a massive explosion
into the to the mid 9 figures of the
number of bitcoin wallets it's gonna
happen faster than people think
that's number one um and then
i i also think we're gonna have this uh
mining fee network fee problem again
network congestion that we had with the
whole and by the way i loved your talk
with roger on this
uh but the problem didn't go away right
we just punted uh via the the uasf and
so
so that's gonna that's gonna come around
again i don't know if it's gonna be ugly
if we're just gonna accept the fact that
we're paying hundred dollar
transaction fees and it is what it is
but i don't it's not clear to me how
we're going to address that
or if we just don't and that's it is
what it is everything's just a net
settlement because
um for people who want to do on-chain
transactions lightning by definition
doesn't help lightning helps
if you want to do small dollar
transactions and don't mind
a semi a semi centralized solution which
is
totally fine that's what it's meant to
be so so that's that's what i'm look
that's the other piece that i'm looking
for is to say
how are core developers going to address
what's likely to happen when bitcoin
does start to get to 25 000
and does this actually become an
artificial
limiting factor in that plan b model
of bitcoin's run-up i would hate to see
that happen
artificially i don't know if it will i
haven't really thought it through but i
i
kind of in the back of my mind it's one
fear i have i think that we need to look
out for
and then from aber's perspective we
think about assets under management
right so
um it's it's very simple right how much
money is in the system
when we announce the the interest
accounts we literally grew assets under
management something like 15
in a few days which for us just doesn't
normally happen that's usually it's a
good
steady growth and so so that's we're
really excited about that
i think you're going to see just a big
big influx of cash
sitting on the sidelines in the west in
particular
into bitcoin um secondarily in ethereum
and defy
a smaller piece but but the vast
majority go into bitcoin over the next
18 months to answer your question
so that's what we're looking for you
want to do a price target
um you know i'll be honest i keep
looking for holes in that
in that stock to flow model and
i have a hard time coming up with holes
in it so so part of me wants to say
you know because i think that the logic
is sound 100 000 by the end of next year
makes sense
uh you know the current price doesn't
necessarily reflect that but
it's it's it would be no less crazy than
what's happened with tesla's shares
since march for sure and so i have no
problem saying 100 000 by the end of 21.
uh yeah i'm there with you man i think
uh i think there's
a higher likelihood of it happening than
not is kind of how i think about it
right so if you had to
you know kind of think of probabilities
in the same time frame that i'm talking
about
yeah and end of 2021 yeah um so we'll
we'll see uh where can we send people to
uh to find you on the internet
and uh find out abra uh so i'm on abra
at bill bar heights uh bill
b-a-r-h-y-d-t my first last name on
twitter
uh abra global on twitter or abra.com
uh to download the app or or get more
information on how how we work
get and even learn about bitcoin if you
have i know you have a lot of people
here
are techies who are new to this they
want to learn get the basics we have a
fantastic
uh 10 day getting started guide
delivered dailyvee email
and then a weekly newsletter that really
digs into the basics
i think it's a good complement to what
you're doing which really kind of it's a
little bit more advanced and necro
economic issues as well
and so the number of people we have
hundreds of thousands of people uh
accessing that content fairly regularly
that's awesome man well listen keep it
up we uh we need as many people building
as possible you are definitely one of
the people leading the charge
so uh we're cheering for you and i'll
have to do this again we'll have to do
episode number four something yeah
there you go i'm an axer paying rent
that says it's to you and zoom
always pleasure man